do you guys have this like like uh
unfounded like
feeling or fear or whatever whenever you
see like a big red emergency button that
you shouldn't press
and your mind's like what if i press
that
no i don't get it i totally get that
like
every time like you go through the
school hallways and they'll be like
the fire alarm one yeah yeah every time
i would just stop and look and be like
god i want to press this
i've never gotten to search because it's
like i feel that's
i feel that's an experience that only
like
the point one percent of you and you
ever got to experience all right like
you just want to press the button yeah
that was almost a bragging right as a
kid i feel being like yeah i pressed i
pressed this button before me like whoa
how was it it's like
of course it's it's like any it's like
pressing any button because i don't know
what the emergency buttons or the fire
alarm buttons you had in your school but
in like british school or my school
we had like this it wasn't a button it
was like a very thin piece of glass yeah
you had to break
yeah and i always wondered what does it
feel like to break that piece of glass
like i i just want to know i just want
to know what happens to my brain yeah
yeah like what does it feel like like
does it hurt
like how thin is it how much how much
force would it take to press
this button i do think you know when
you're on a bus sometimes you see that
little
puny little hammer it'll be like this
giant window and there'll be this tiny
little like it looks like a
little pick an ice pick that's another
one every time i came back from school
and i saw that little hammer i was like
i want to use that because i think what
happens is when you literally that thing
like
touches the thing it just shatters yeah
yeah i was on a bus one time when the
windows exploded
really really yeah so what happened was
is
i was in near the back of the bus and
it was in university and it was a
varsity event so they drove the bus to
the
like one hour university over from from
swansea to cardiff yeah
and um when we were on our way back
the bus drive went down the wrong road
now as you probably are aware
roads in the uk if you don't go on the
right one with the bus it's way too
narrow
right right so what happened was that he
went down the wrong road
and he had to turn around but it was
like a like the road was like this right
it's like a three-point
like yeah so he went down this way and
so he backed it up the hill to try and
turn around and as he was trying to
swing the bus back round
the the house that was in like the end
of this road
had like a pointing out like uh thing on
the edge of their property right right
like a tile
and so as the bus is turning you could
see
i saw because i was sitting here like on
this side and that was the side where
the window was
right you could just see this thing
coming right i think they were like
started screaming when they saw it
because it was getting real close and it
just went
and just exploded the window wow oh my
god yeah yeah and then the guy obviously
heard the [ __ ] shadow and was like oh
so he backed up
goes to try it again boom other window
goes
and there's clash everywhere was was
that like
in near any other students or yeah but
they all ran to the other side
so like it was like it was terrifying
and then the the bus driver didn't stop
or anything he just like
he i'ma try this again he smashed i
think in total three
of the big ass windows on the side of
the bus and then just drove back
like normal i'm i'm sitting here like
glass everywhere like
what do i do did the glass explode on
someone yeah but the thing is right uh
the windows when the
it's car windows do this as well when uh
they smash they're meant to
they're like the way they're made the
windows smash into like non-shock
they're like
they're like blunt little little like
balls yeah they don't they don't like
cut anyone it's still a scary it was
[ __ ] terrifying
that's what happened afterwards what
happened was that we just drove
the last 20 minutes with no windows on
the side and then we got off and
everyone was like
what the [ __ ] and we all went and was
like what the [ __ ] just happened
and i'm sure that guy lost his job oh
yeah probably no idea what happened
university never said anything
no we didn't hear anything how old were
you guys
i was like 20. oh okay oh so this is
like a university bus this is my third
year of university and i was like what
the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i just went on with my day
i was like all right that was weird
jesus christ yeah never heard anything
about that felt like i deserved an
apology for having glass
flashing my face was it loud oh yes
you ever heard glass explode no i
haven't